everything in our world is made up of
atoms yep everything from the air we
breathe to the water we drink even the
materials inside our cell phones but
what are atoms exactly what's inside of
these atoms what makes an atom an atom
atoms are tiny particles that are basic
units of matter like building blocks but
atoms themselves are made up of even
smaller subatomic particles called
protons neutrons and electrons
let's take a look at the simplified
diagram to learn more about these
subatomic particles and the structure of
an atom
in the center of an atom we have the
nucleus which is composed of protons and
neutrons
outside the nucleus we have the electron
cloud this is where electrons are most
likely to be found
I've drawn the nucleus much larger than
it really is but an atom's electron
cloud can be 100 000 times larger than
its nucleus so the electron cloud
actually makes up most of the atom's
volume
protons neutrons and electrons differ in
terms of their charge and mass let's
take a look at charge first
protons have a positive charge of one
plus and electrons have a negative
charge of one minus
these charges are equal and opposite so
when protons and electrons are paired in
atoms their charges cancel
neutrons have no charge which means they
are neutral
what about Mass the unit we use to
express the masses of subatomic
particles is the unified atomic mass
unit abbreviated as U
protons and neutrons have a similar mass
about one U
in comparison electrons have a mass of
about
0.0005 U which makes them roughly 2 000
times smaller than either a proton or a
neutron
this means that nearly all the mass of
an atom resides in the nucleus and not
in the electron cloud
atoms make up everything in our world
even though the air we breathe the water
we drink and the cell phones we use all
look really different from one another
the atoms that make up these things are
all composed of the same subatomic
particles protons neutrons and electrons